My liver numbers, ALT, ST, and one with a really long name,
alkaline phosphatase probably, are all going up.
Do you think if I back off of the fed band in Ivermectin,
it will go down, or should I back off on some of the supplements?
So, if the only change is taking the fed band is all Ivermectin,
and supplements again, it's the fed band is all that's causing it.
It's not the Ivermectin, most likely, it's certainly not the supplements.
So, remember, one of the side effects of doing fed band is all,
is that many people probably 50% of the population don't detoxify it well.
That's kind of the going rate to it by patients.
50% of the people don't detoxify fed band is all real well,
and they have to keep an eye on their liver markers.
They're ALT, AST, and alkaline phosphatase.
If you do that by running a comprehensive metabolic panel,
so that will include those numbers at Billy Room,
and some other things that you want to look at.
But if ALT, AST, and alkaline phosphatase is going up,
your liver is stressed.
So, pretty much guarantee it's the fed band is all.
Now, I've had people that are doing something else,
some other drug like chemo or something at the same time,
then it's hard to discern because chemo therapy can certainly do that.
The fed band is all has been a common culprit.
So, I would just back off on the fed band is all,
you could probably still take the liver back in,
and you could definitely take the sun.
I am also doing IV vitamin C, 50,000 grams,
the disk drive up liver numbers.
No, no, I've never seen that in a moment.
So, but I've seen again,
the fed band is all 50% of the people take it,
then that will happen.